hey remember this unicorn we're going to
talk more about setup and pay off a
[Music]
couple days ago I got this comment in
response to the suicide squad review so
let's quickly do a clearer dive into
what's really the essence of setup and
payoff now in the previous video I
mentioned the rule of threes where an
element will be set up then there's a
reminder and then finally a payoff this
idea meshes with another dramatic
principle of Chekhov's gun anton chekhov
was a prolific russian author and
playwright in the mid late 1800s he
believes strongly in narrative
efficiency and thought stories should
have formal rules of construction which
is why we have the phrase Chekhov's gun
remove everything that has no relevance
to the story if you say in the first
chapter that there is a rifle hanging on
the wall in the second or third chapter
it absolutely must go off if it's not
going to be fired it shouldn't be
hanging there the unicorn and suicide
squad is unusual it's an absurdist
element it breaks from expectations and
thus definitionally calls attention to
itself this is why we or at least I
expect something to come of it now let's
go back and look at that comment
wouldn't the title card be the intro
when we first see it - the reminder and
then the fight the payoff now the
comment makes a critical error in
evaluating the rule of threes which is
holding too tightly to the idea of three
the idea isn't just that something
should show up three times but as per
Chekhov's gun it should do something
even though the unicorn appears or is
referenced three different times none of
these actually come to anything three is
really just a convenient number it has a
good rhythm and once something has
happened three times in a row we
instinctively start to feel like it is
intentional rather than random three is
indicative of a pattern even simpler
than the psychology of patterns though
is just basic information juggling
managing the human memory if someone is
watching a movie or a play or television
they're actually taking in a lot of
information at
more or less constant rate for upwards
of several hours the reminder stage of
the rule of threes is really just about
helping the audience keep track of
something set up in the first 20 minutes
that's not going to be relevant for
another two hours if the span of time
between set up and pay off is much
shorter then there's no need for a
reminder because it's still fresh in the
audience's mind well if the time between
is much much longer than either you'll
need more reminders or you'll just need
to spend more time embedding it in the
audience's memory but even that still
isn't getting to the heart of the issue
and to do that we're going to take a
look at an episode of The Simpsons
season three
Bart's friend falls in love centers
around Bart and Milhouse having a
falling out over the new girl in class
as a start of the episode Milhouse shows
Bart his new magic 8-ball they ask it
several questions and the 8-ball
predicts that they won't be friends by
the end of the day sure enough Milhouse
falls in love with Samantha's new girl
in class
Bart resents the change in his
relationship with Milhouse and the two
have a falling out that culminates in
Bart snitching on Samantha to her father
who has her transferred to a private
girls school feeling guilty about the
grief he's caused Milhouse Bart
confesses to Milhouse and Milhouse
attacks him mark grabs the 8 ball and
hits Milhouse in the head breaking it
[Music]
so this is all over with and a half hour
including commercial breaks so there's
not really any pressing need for a
reminder just the set up in the payoff
the set up is that the introduction of
the eight-ball into the relationship
heralds the forming of a risk while the
payoff is that the violent destruction
of the eight-ball marks the healing of
that risk a peaceful friendly
interaction with the eight-ball moves
the emotional state into chaos a chaotic
violent interaction moves the emotional
state into peace the eight-ball being
used for its intended purpose brings
discord brings a prophecy that dooms the
protagonist and the destruction of the
eight-ball using it as a weapon breaks
the curse and breaks the power of the
eight-ball over the relationship the
writer could have used anything for this
gag but by using the eight-ball it forms
an emotionally satisfying loop which is
the essence of payoff a stuffed unicorn
flying out of boomerangs jacket isn't
emotionally satisfying
[Music]